all right my dear so much to catch up
with you on first I want to ask you a
couple little Dancing with the Stars
question shoo it away can you watch the
show when you're not on the judges panel
you do miss the show you know but what's
really fun is I'm a fan just like
everybody who watches you know I watch
the show now that I'm home and you know
I have favorites and everything which is
great cuz I could never really have
favorites I had to really kind of you
know separate that who are your
favorites so far the seasons I love
Derek I think he's phenomenal
I love Lindsey Stirling she's just a
just a bubble and bright light of fresh
air
Sasha she's great she's got such a fun
personality and like she can really move
I mean Jordan Fischer we did grease
together so yeah he's phenomenal he's so
great neither you nor Derek on the show
this season we miss both of you guys
yeah they're a return in the future for
you or Derek have you guys talked about
that honestly like Dancing with the
Stars ABC they're our family like we
love them I hope they love us too
but yeah but it's something that I mean
I always feel like I'll be a part of it
in some way shape or form you know
obviously right now I I wanted to take
some time to focus on my acting and kind
of get back on that path it's
interesting I did two and a half years
as a dancer I left for five years and
then I was on the show for two and a
half years as a judge and so now I'm
like okay I'm ready to you know get back
on that path again Julianne is currently
working with Fitbit to train for her
role as fitness legend Betty wieder in
the upcoming movie bigger
I'm really excited you know this is a
this is a different chapter I'm you know
I'm 29 and I feel like you know I'm sort
of coming into my own being married all
of those things that just sort of like I
feel this maturity that has kind of just
happened in the piece and in just a
direction that I want to go towards and
I know that if I if I you know keep
doing what I'm doing and stuff like that
I'm gonna wake up in a couple years and
be like oh man I wish I would have done
it you know when I when I really wanted
to do it so I just it was really hard
but I you know
I wanted to make that choice so
[Music]
you